hey everybody i'm ethan and i'm ela
and these
are our favorite
[Music]
snacks this is
super super classic for anyone growing
up in israel it's not this exact brand
this is a little like
brand have you seen this
wow it's called crambo no
traditionally you freeze these right
freezing it is an option that's optional
that's what the cool kids do yeah this
is an israeli snack that that the ila
introduced me to marshmallow marshmallow
dipped in chocolate on a graham cracker
there you go you said i think it tastes
like [ __ ] the thing about these is that
they use the worst ingredients like
theoretically it could be good right i
agree with you but that's part of the
joy
that's the best exactly cheers
all right this tastes pretty legit
all right next step
you're gonna include that
next up one of mine
warheads when i was a kid this is like
where you earned your stripes the
warheads field source candy ever blew
our minds dude we threw these down like
uh multivitamins you go through the pain
and then you get a little bit of
sweetness and it's all the more sweet
cheers
oh my god
oh god this is just as bad as i remember
of course
i really wanna get out
[Music]
are we doing it
i feel like i'm a puke i'd love to just
say it's watermelon it does not wobble
out
it tastes like stomach bites yeah
okay push through the worst of
everything
getting a little sweetness now
and then you're like oh we made it
dab me up dude we made it we made it
that's fine you dab what oh god come
from the bottom
yep stop
dab me up
next one of mine's beastly this is
something israel got really really good
right love this we did something it says
on the front flavored wheat snack it's
like a really dense sun chip
it's pizza flavor this one's pizza
flavored they come in all kinds of
flavors i think they're all good it's
real chewy almost reminiscent of like
dog food
but in a good way
very chewy you know what i mean
it's real thick and chewy
and we love that
i don't know what dog food looks like
kibble it feels like kibble definitely
brings me back just to my childhood like
growing up this is the kind of stuff
that i would eat it's just like such a
classic israeli snack yep oh it's cold
too okay i see you guys
this is like some underground deep
level
soda and when i was a kid we would hold
up play video games and slam cactus
cooler i'm talking ungodly amount like
five in a day five in an hour
no way
you know what's funny on the cover it
says orange pineapple soda i didn't even
even knew it had a flavor
until now i just thought it was just
cactus cooler but i'm excited for you to
try it yeah i actually haven't had one
in probably 20 years i used to love
orange soda like we had uh font on
that is so good
it doesn't get better
that's nice
wait so why don't i see it more yeah i
don't know what happened to the cactus
cooler the i think the branding's a
little weird cactus they're having
trouble with the branding so this one's
for you guys
[Music]
nice
that's it that's a s here
all right
uh next up is one of mine's bamba
and then there's bomba chocolate and red
bamboo
bombas like cheetos but peanut butter
flavor bombay is so special because in
israel it's like
not only do you grow up on it
it's also something you give babies
again very nostalgic especially this one
it's like really old school also blessed
by the rabbinite so
how many y'all can say that about your
snacks
next up this is my pick atomic fireball
no of course it's so you it's like
atomic to be fair this was just what
kids ate when i was a kid it's
interactive it's fun it's a whole
experience and this is a lot like the
warheads where it's just spicy and then
it's sweet okay i don't think i've ever
had you ever had one so yeah this this
is another thing that was really good
for my mouth i went from battery acid to
like pepper spraying my mouth perfect no
wonder i have digestion problems and
then wash it off with the soda i go why
do i why do i [ __ ] blood all the time oh
damn
it smells you know atomic all right
ready
see if you can make it
you feeling the heat i'm getting there
yeah
and look
i've done the hot ones
there it is oh
but this is hot right this is
competitive this this [ __ ] is no bloom
it's kind of big that's what she's come
on it's not getting any smaller
that's what she said
how much longer is this gonna go for
i can't tell you you're on your own
journey you're on like a peyote journey
right now
you're in the k hole well the third
ingredient
the semen of a decapitated demon that's
good this might be the worst
thing i feel like i got pepper straight
in the mouth
[Music]
thanks for watching guys you know that
was fun actually yeah i feel like we
bought like
yeah we went through a lot together yeah
yeah
i want to plug something um howie mandel
good friend of mine posted on tick tock
a prolapse anus and
i just i want people to go check that
out freaking massive prolapse anus and i
got like three million views so i just
want to say thanks for watching and if
you want to check out the h3 podcast or
teddy fresh oh you're welcome to thank
you guys for having us we had so much
fun hope you have us again
the fifth high five we're doing today
all right
[Music]
you